this episode of the minimalist is
brought to you by
nobody because advertisements suck
minimalists hello everybody
welcome to the minimalist podcast where
we discuss what it means to live a
meaningful life
with less my name is joshua fields
milburn and i'm ryan nicodemus and
together we are the minimalists today
we're going to talk about hidden clutter
what do you have on you ryan a face mask
oh yeah that's not clutter well let me
let me ask you this if you're listening
to this have you
minimized some of your stuff maybe
recently maybe over the last year or a
couple years or maybe you just saw
less's now and you're like
i've got to do that challenge right now
maybe you've minimized some stuff
but now you realize that you have all
kinds of hidden clutter
in your life could be physical clutter
or maybe it's emotional clutter
psychological clutter
media clutter relational clutter
career clutter mental clutter
digital clutter what about looking
inside us that internal
clutter you know minimalism starts with
the stuff
but then it goes way beyond that when
you and i talk about minimalism ryan
we're talking about living
an intentional life a meaningful life
with less
it's not a life with nothing but when we
start clearing the external clutter we
realize that our material possessions
are a physical manifestation
of what's going on inside us and so then
we start dealing with all of that
additional clutter now ryan you and i
recently been talking about how
the solution is the problem and and
and prescriptions don't work now
what we mean by that is there are a lot
of nuances
and so ryan and i don't like to
prescribe one size fits all things but
when it comes to clutter this is one of
those areas
where the how to's can be really
helpful yeah right because it's a it's a
basic
mechanical thing i think we all know
fundamentally how to
declutter but if you want to do it a
little more efficiently
then following in the footsteps of
someone who has decluttered in the past
and sort of taking some of their rules
to heart
applying it to your own life that can
really help yeah
we've got this essay on our website
called how to let go of
possessions if you're on our email list
you've probably seen it
but i thought this would be a great way
to start this podcast episode ryan
because
it's really short and it really
describes ryan's in my process it's not
saying this is what you should do
it's simply saying here's one way to let
go
our possessions possess us this
is how we let go if a thing stops adding
value
sell it if it doesn't sell in a week
lower the price if it doesn't sell in 30
days donate it
if a donation place doesn't accept it
recycle it if it can't be recycled
trash it as a last resort once we let go
we're able to move on
it makes me think of how we get
questions about oh i can't get rid of my
stuff
because i have to throw it away and it's
going into a landfill and i don't want
to
hurt the environment and uh
yeah i just think about well if it's in
a landfill it's going to decomp
even though even if it's like a plastic
or whatever something that decomposes
uh it takes 500 years to decompose it's
going to
decompose faster in the landfill than it
is in your house
right right and taking up all that extra
space so and as soon as you bought
yeah and as soon as you bought that
product you've already hurt the
environment
yeah yeah and so what we're talking
about when we're talking about
letting go we're talking about letting
go intentionally not letting go of
everything but
questioning these items and then we have
a whole process there of
letting go trying to sell it if it
doesn't sell in a week lower the price
if
you can't sell in 30 days then you
donate it right now i did this
especially when i was
trying to get out of debt ryan when i
first started
decluttering that eight month process of
letting go craigslist and ebay became my
best friend
because i was so jealous
it was temporary ryan it was a little
fling
it won't happen again you thought about
me the whole time
[Laughter]
i wish i could sell these on nicodemus
but
anyway i was trying to get out of debt
and so i would sell anything that was
over twenty dollars and so you can
figure out what that threshold what's
appropriate
for you especially have debt but the key
was still getting rid of it
well i'm still i put this up here it's
35
but no one's bought it in seven months
well no no no no
this putting a a deadline on there for
me forced me
to move in that direction now ryan we're
talking about clutter
let's talk about clutter because we're
talking about hidden clutter today
another essay on our website called what
is
clutter our clutter isn't relegated only
to material things we clutter our lives
with
destructive relationships careers
obligations rituals
busyness minutiae news media politics
gossip drama rumors we clutter our
attention with glowing screens
we clutter our creativity with
distractions we clutter our free time
with trivialities
we clutter our desires with attachments
our lives are brimming with existential
clutter
emotional clutter mental clutter
spiritual clutter
so much so that it's hard to distinguish
what is
clutter and what is not we are stressed
out
overwhelmed and anxious because we
filled our lives with disorder
chaos there is another way though
look at an object a commitment a habit
does it bring tranquility or increase
your well-being
if not let it go
not an easy path but a simple one
so i think that question will really be
the foundation
for this episode and subsequent maximal
episode
does it bring tranquility or increase
your well-being
and if so why would you you definitely
don't want to get rid of it right
yeah there are a lot of things you own
ryan that add immense value to your life
yeah a lot of important things and
minimalists don't get rid of important
things
right and because you you would be
depriving yourself
yeah and of course you would just
replace it then a week or a month or
whatever later
because you're like i don't want to
deprive myself of this i remember when
we first came up with the
minimalists.com and
our boss called me in his office we were
like having our weekly one-on-one
and he was like oh i saw your minimalist
stuff
he's like you're not a minimalist you
snowboard and all that crap that comes
with your snowboarding and
you can't call yourself a minimalist and
i was like i can't
[Laughter]
oh no maybe he's right but no uh
it's it's interesting how the word
minimalism
and you know we've talked about this how
it conjures up some really extreme
lifestyle
uh lifestyle i don't know thoughts like
you know monks or buddhists or whatever
but but yeah i mean
really it's it's a tool that helps us to
keep that which is most important
and by the way that snowboard thing if
he were to say that to me he would
actually be right
because yeah i was holding on to your
snowboard and snowboard equipment
but i i tried it once didn't really like
it but you know i'll hold on to it just
in case
right then of course i wouldn't that
wouldn't be a minimalist
decision because it'd be clinging yeah
to something that is
actually getting in the way right not
bringing tranquility not serving
my well-being a few examples here ryan
uh since we've had a lot of folks doing
the less is now
challenge this month by the way a new
month is right around the corner we also
call it the 30 day minimalism game same
thing
you can find details at the
minimalists.com game it's free to play
you can even download a free calendar
over there
and join tens of thousands of people are
sharing it with the hashtag
less is now or hashtag men's game that's
the old one m-i-n-s-g-a-m-e
ryan here is something that blew my mind
so this is from minimalist.org
minimalist.org is a 100 meetup groups
that we have in 100 different cities a
lot of them are meeting online now for
obvious
reasons but also if we're not in one of
those hundred cities we have the online
city yeah for anyone around the world
even antarctica
everywhere except saskatchewan it's not
available there
sorry saskatchewan oh my goodness we're
still trying to get there though oh man
one day we'll get internet you know
someone's like saskatchewan has internet
i love that's the thing i love saskatoon
we've done tour stuff there yeah uh
regina as well
anyway minimalist.org 100 different
local meetup groups in eight different
countries
also there's an online city there and
liz let's put a link to this post in the
show notes
sean i sent you a copy of it but liz
i i think this is a world record ryan
this has to be we'd need
call up guinness podcast sean the beer
company not the
the world record books and celebrate
with uh 46 months of letting go listen
to this ryan
liz she's been posting this here i've
been following along here
month 46 days 15 16
and 17. wow think about that
she has been doing the minimalism game
for 46 months yes
so she's starting over each month yes
although i have seen some people who
continue going on day 32 33
for those who don't know how it works
ryan i'll give you a brief overview
of the of the minimalist game yeah yeah
so uh you find
someone who wants to declutter and you
challenge them to the men's game
and basically what you do is you agree
to start on the first day of the next
month um in fact mariah and i i think
we're gonna do this
in february because uh it's a shorter
month
no that's not why we just we were going
to start january 1st and uh
we just we didn't get to it so i think
we're going to start in february but you
start on the first day of the month
you agree to get rid of one item and
then on the second day of the month you
get rid of two items then on the third
day of the month three items
and then on the fourth day how many
items josh wow let me do my math
get the abacus it's four hours so you
all get the yeah i learned though ryan
what's up because becks and i've been
playing the game this month yes and uh
in fact you can go to her instagram
account it's just at
minimal wellness you can see pictures of
everything that we as a family have
gotten let go of we didn't
we didn't uh compete against each other
what we decided to do was like we don't
have
we can't each get rid of 500 items this
month so
basically we just got rid of 500 of
ella's toys and it's been fine ever
since
right you can see you could we did get
rid of some ella's toys sure
and had discussions with her about that
and but um
we all got rid of some stuff this month
and i realized that it actually gets
hard right around
day seven if you're already a minimalist
oh
i could see that uh now and it's just
because day seven
and it's like well wait a minute seven
things and tomorrow is eight things
and you will you'll be really surprised
and you'll crack up at what we got rid
of on day
31 uh which is coming up soon i'm not
gonna i'm not gonna spoil it for you now
but you can find it on her instagram
account at minimal
wellness and anyway ryan back to liz
46 months of the minimalism game it's
insane
or less is now challenge as we're
calling it because of the film
and we've had so many new people hopping
on board with that in fact we've had
folks
who have been scanning things and we've
got questions about that today
so i thought maybe we could dive into
some of these
questions here right let's talk about
this so if you do it every month
uh i'm sorry if you finish and you go
through the entire month you get rid of
almost 500 things
yeah so i'm just trying to do the math
here with liz she has done
she's gotten rid of 23 000 items yeah 23
000
well she says so far she has 15 200
items
because it's not quite 500 right
so it's uh it's 496 items if you have 31
days in the month and you can just do
the math from
from there and so yeah in february it's
it's i think it's like maybe even less
than
four it's right around 400 in february
so you're right it is the easier month
so what's what's fun about this or what
you can make fun about this is you can
kind of bet something silly with your
partner that you're
you know or your friend or family member
or foe whoever you're playing this game
with uh
mariah and randy you know randy randy
kaye
former podcast guest randy yes what is
her uh does she still do the
simple self-care is the name of her
podcast yeah so she's got uh she's got
some
self-care tips there you can go check
her out but her and randy did this
uh they i think it was the the loser had
to like
lip sync a song and like do a dance or
something okay i don't know what it was
but i was like i was like oh it's a good
idea
or i was thinking you could do uh
someone has to like wear a really funny
hat for like a week or
i don't know man be careful there's a
particular hat that someone might make
you wear
i said a funny hat yeah all right all
right what do we got here we got some
questions here first from
lauren in huntsville alabama you've
mentioned
that you can take pictures of things to
stimulate memories that way you can let
go of the physical object
but how often do you actually reference
those old pictures and what are some
methods for
dealing with digital clutter
so ryan if we're talking about digital
clutter that is a
type of hidden clutter that sure we have
to be really careful now here's the
thing
because there's this weird blurred line
as well
if you have the internet at your house
then you have access to infinite
digital clutter yeah and and it's not
just infinite it's growing
at an exponential rate yeah and so
you have access to all that clutter
that's on
the internet so let's pretend for a
moment that we're not talking about the
internet clutter that's out there
because
you can't clean up everyone else's
clutter right maybe that you could tweet
that podcast sean
so ryan if i'm hearing lauren correctly
if i were to rephrase her question sum
it up i would say
how do we curate photos so we're not
trading physical clutter for digital
clutter first thing i will say is i
don't think
that digital clutter is as big of a
problem as physical
clutter i think it can still be a
problem sure but overall
if you have a giant warehouse full of
stuff
or a hard drive full of digital stuff
yeah which is going to be more
burdensome for
you now you might say well because of
you know
ocd that i have or whatever the digital
stuff okay then fine then
it's a bigger problem for you not for me
to judge right
yeah and so when i look at at the
physical clutter i do see it as a bigger
problem it weighs us down
literally and figuratively the sort of
it creates psychological clutter
yeah in our minds so
photo scanning rule is obviously
something that stands out to me right
away mm-hmm
it's in the minimalist rule book the
minimalist rule i'm sorry the
minimalists.com slash
rulebook and we have 16 rules for living
with less there it's a free
e-book you can download it's also
available as an audio book
and the photo scanning party
is it's a it came off your idea of the
packing party but
you invite someone over and you scan
some photos together
in fact i just have i have this uh tweet
from
the 76 is the
twitter handle shop and i'll link to
this in the show notes you can see
someone here it says
10 years of paperwork down to this but
i'm putting i've been putting this off
for
years yeah and so truthfully what what
the what did this person probably do
they probably threw out shredded most of
their paperwork well it's interesting
because when you have a scanning party
whether it's with documents or whether
it's with pictures you get really clear
on what's actually important and what
you want to keep
because it takes some work to like scan
all that stuff so yeah you're right
they're probably going through it and
they're like
old bank statements and they're like
well i could either scan this or i could
just shred it
and so it forces you to make a decision
it forces you to get clear on what
you actually want to hold on to right
and so you have
three options there right hold on to it
physically scan
it now you could do a combination of
those two sometimes it makes sense if
you need a physical backup for some
let's say a birth certificate for
example that's helpful it's also helped
helpful to have a scanned copy of that
in case
there's a fire you lose it yeah and so
that's a a redundancy that makes a lot
of sense to me however most of the
things fall into that junk
category that third category were like
old bank statements from 1997.
i should never have old bank statements
now it doesn't make sense to me
to hold on to those bank statements so i
can just let those go i can shred them
and
and be done with it now i know a lot of
people if you want to do
there's sort of three things that you
can do to scan old
photos old documents and even
books so we can talk about that the
first thing is the
the photo scanning party uh the
minimalists.com
rule book if you want to read about that
you can even see the scanner that ryan
and i use i like
that as an option because it does make
it communal
and so i can invite you over we can go
through old pictures
you can look at my old bank statements
man look how broke he used to be
josh how did you make it this long oh my
goodness the second option
is you can scan your you can send your
photos off
somewhere so there are a bunch of places
in fact i found this article with like
the top 10 places
sean if you put a link to that in the
show notes uh the one i have
gotten feedback on i've never used it
myself is scanmyphotos.com oh cool i've
been hearing another one i
reviewed their website and that forbes
also did a write-up about them
as well and apparently they have really
good customer service they they're
california-based but you can just send
your photos
to them you can also send some documents
and things that
to them and then they will scan all them
and they'll send it back to you they'll
even do like photo albums if you want to
do that
because here's the nice thing about
scanning photos you can put them in a
digital picture frame
and people all of a sudden feel
compelled to look at a glowing screen
right i'm not sure why that is but if i
i come over to your house right and on
your mantel you have a picture of you
surfing in hawaii i might look at it but
if it's on
a digital picture frame i don't know why
but i'm like captivated
yeah well i mean you know glowing
screens are pretty captivating but also
it's
the pictures are changing too right so
there's like a nice little slideshow
going because yeah if you
were to come over to my house and bring
a photo album
and be like hey sit down and look at
this it'll be like why are you making me
look at your photos
one other uh service ryan if you want to
scan documents or books
there's a place called one dollar scan
we've talked about them on the podcast
in the past
the number one or the numeral one dollar
scan dot com i'll put a link to that in
the show notes as well
they you can send them your books so
like say i have this book the way to
love by anthony demelo
i could send this to them they'll cut it
open they'll scan the whole book page by
page by page and they do a really high
quality job apparently
according to the reviews that i've read
again i haven't used this myself
and this is not an ad we don't do
advertisements advertisements suck
and we wouldn't do an advertisement for
them anyway so
i just i've heard heard people ask about
this so i could send this book in ryan
or all my books in
and they scanned them for one dollar a
page i don't know i don't think that's
it i'm kidding
but they do scan the book and then they
dispose of the books and the documents
for you
and so you don't have to deal with that
clutter nice get rid of the clutter for
you
right and they can even provide you with
like a physical disk
as well as an upload and so they have a
bunch of different options for folks so
if you want to have books you're like
i've been wanting to get rid of this
textbook but you know i i guess i
shouldn't i need it just in case
you can scan it and you can let it go in
fact they'll let it go for you
that's the easiest way to let go is have
someone steal your stuff and
let go of it for you that's right uh i
like lauren's question about how often
do you actually look at those photos how
often do you go back and look at photos
great question uh and here's why that's
a great question it really is because
uh there are two answers to this
if i think the cynical side of that
question is yeah but how do
and i don't think this is this is what
lauren's asking it but the cynical side
is
yeah you're going to scan all those
photos but how often do you go back and
listen
and watch them yeah right or with the
music it could be listen or old dvds how
often do you go back and watch those
yeah that that's a fair fair question
it's not about going back and looking at
all of them and this that's why this is
a good question because
it's it's about having access to
any of them that i want perfect example
for you we were making less is now
uh the film on netflix and when we were
going through that
there were a bunch of pictures i hadn't
looked at in many many years
but i just typed in jfm childhood
and so how do i organize my my photos
it's simple it's the name of the person
in the picture the approximate year in
which it was in the setting
so if it's at newcomb park in dayton
ohio
that's all we'll say of say jfm
ryan nukem park dayton ohio 2011.
and that's it and it makes it
eminently searchable so that i don't
have to worry about going back and
looking at them but i have access to
them
if and when i need them but it's a fair
question because
the truth is there are a lot of them i
won't ever go back and look at and
that's okay too
yeah it's it's uh interesting on
my iphone again not an advertisement
they have this program which is a little
scary but it's kind of awesome
they basically do facial recognition
and they will create albums for you
based on who you're with in pictures
yeah i have that turned off but bex has
been using that
she likes it awesome man like it made me
realize like i sat there and played the
sledge of uh
mariah and i and it was great man it was
so i mean like so many things that i
you know trips we went on uh things that
i forgot about
and yeah i mean i don't look at those
often but
i what i used to do is i would uh just
go to my photos and because i'll delete
duplicates
you know like there's a picture of me
with you know my thumb and then the
lens or whatever so like i get rid of
stuff like that
um but what's nice is when i'm going
through curating those photos i can go
back and kind of look
at these moments and they're great like
there's a lot of memories getting
triggered and um
helps me remember all these trips we've
been on and um
yeah it's it's amazing because yeah the
memories are not
uh in the things they are in us but
these pictures
like trigger memories that i had you
know would not have thought about
otherwise yeah and i remember when i was
getting rid of my mom's stuff
i took pictures of a lot of her items
right so that i could
trigger those memories that have been
inside me all along the memories are not
in those things
as ryan just said but those things can
be triggers but the photos
there's an occasional exception i'm sure
about the tactileness or whatever but
not really like if we're honest with
ourselves we look ourselves in the
mirror and say
i really need the tactile experience of
her 800 pound armoire
no i can take a picture of it now i have
access to that
trigger for the memories that are inside
me i
am whenever i'm on an airplane so this
has happened a lot less frequently
recently
because of what current events and
but that's the time that i go through my
photos and delete duplicates
and it's also the time where i go
through and look at because it's such a
well-curated
a list of photos a collection a
well-curated collection of photos
on the phone
i am able to go through them and say oh
look at that cute picture of ella oh my
god
it was a year ago but she seemed so much
small or whatever
and and as i'm going through that now i
need a new trigger now
right because i don't get on airplanes
anymore so
it needs to be uh i don't know i don't
know what it needs to be yet maybe let
me know
comment on youtube let me know what a
good trigger is to go through my photo
album is it the first of the month is
whenever i change my air filter to my
air conditioner
what is the trigger let us know on
youtube youtube comments youtube.com
the minimalists lauren let's get you a
copy of that minimalist rule book
the minimalists.com rule book if you
want the audiobook version we'll send
you
that one or the ebook version is free
over there on
the website zack in new york city has a
question for us
i've been listening to your podcast and
it's really been interesting
and i've heard you talk about a lot of
things but a lot of things are for
people who are older and moved out and
out of college or getting a job
but i'm only 17 and i'm really
interested in learning more about this
so do you have any advice for anyone as
young as 16 or 17 and
want to declutter and make their lives
more simpler
oh man could you imagine having this
mentality
at 16 or 17 years old like the things i
could have avoided
like uh getting into debt uh like
chasing the wrong
things um you know what's interesting
though i
if i could give like let's say you give
your 16 year old self
one piece of advice um for me
i think it would be getting clear on
what my values are
and you know uh those change over time
certainly my values are different today
than what they were
at 16 or 17 years old especially the
surface values and the structural values
absolutely but if i could have gotten
clear on what those values were
and when went out of my way to
deliberately
take actions that are in alignment with
those values i think i would have been
so much better off and i think he's
doing the right thing
by you know listening to of course he's
doing the right thing by listening to
our podcast but
but no just going out and you know we
didn't have podcasts available when we
were
you know that age no but how cool is it
that he can go and listen to
us he can go and listen to someone like
dave ramsey
or you know whoever that uh he can kind
of look up to and get their recipe for
living
i wish i would have had that at 17 man
so what advice would you give your
16 or 17 year old self if you could give
yourself only one piece of advice yeah i
i wouldn't give him any advice but i i
would
i would observe something in front of
him
that would help him get a deeper
understanding so so whether it's zach or
it is my
younger self the observation about the
values ryan i
i think is is spot on because what we're
really talking about here
isn't the clutter it's understanding
what leads to the clutter
right and and so of course there are
some sort of pithy things that i could
say
like um the uh something about clutter
um is avoided by you know leave by
leaving it at the store
or or the best way to declutter is to
leave the junk at the store that's the
pithy answer for you but i think we can
understand that intellectually
right but when we understand that in the
heart viscerally
understand it the way the only way to do
that
is to understand what is behind the
clutter
and it's about it's it's almost always
about some form of inadequacy
we talk about filling the void right
well there is no void
you've been sold the void by
advertisers yeah by marketers
by peers really absolutely by your peers
right
and by your society and your culture as
a result of that
yeah and so you've been told that you're
incomplete
you've been convinced that you're
incomplete
and whenever we show up empty
we're never going to be filled up by
stuff
by people by achievements by so-called
success we're going to talk about
success on next week's podcast
and how we're all successfuls in a way
f-o-o-l-s and so
having an understanding of what i was
chasing would have probably helped
me drop the chasing altogether
yeah if i truly understood it and got
out of the tethers the clutches
the talons of my peer group yeah
absolutely zach i'd love to send you a
copy of our book everything that remains
it's a
story of the start of the minimalist
journey as we started letting go we were
certainly much younger than we are now
we were back in our 20s and um it
it really goes through the first 30
years of our life 32 years
really of our lives from being growing
up poor but then being these suit and
tie corporate guys
and then eventually becoming minimalist
and then the minimalists and a lot of
the
that path and lessons we learned along
that path if you like our podcast you'll
like the audiobook version of
everything that remains it's still my
favorite thing that we've ever written
everything that remains is also
available as a print book or
an ebook we're happy to send those to
you as well it's a good one i feel like
we need to mention to him the values
worksheet as well oh
yeah i think it's yeah because you're
saying understanding your values
yeah so yeah uh you can go to the
minimalists.com
forward slash v as in values
and you can find a worksheet there zach
to help guide you in
uh getting clear on what those values
are for you
and that essay that's at that that url
also
will help you understand the different
types of values we believe there are
four
types of values and then we categorize
them
accordingly ryan what time is it you
know what time it is it is time for our
lightning round
where we answer your text messages you
can text your questions and comments to
937-202-4654
yes indeed those texts go to both of our
phones and we do respond to
quite a few people either here on the
podcast or even we dip into those texts
and
respond to them as well folks are
sending pictures of what they've
decluttered recently
they're sending emojis yeah
pick your favorite emoji send it on over
937-202-4654
now during the lightning round this is
where ryan and i do our best to answer
questions with a short shareable less
than 140 character response we put the
text to these minimal maxims in the show
notes
so you can copy and share our pithy
answers on social media if you'd like
and now you can find all of our minimal
maxims in one place
minimalmaxims.com all right sebastian's
question
he writes in in the not so distant past
we have many different physical
artifacts for our media
books cds dvds now
we have eliminated that physical clutter
with digital subscriptions audible
apple music netflix apps but we've
swapped one problem for another
we now have a plethora of digital
subscriptions to
address all of our tastes instead of the
physical
artifacts how do we now appropriately
curate these
multiple digital subscriptions and still
satisfy ourselves
since each service has programs
exclusive
to its platform what a well-written
question
it's also the longest lightning round
question ever it's gonna say like that
is
they maximized every character on
twitter there but
it's very well written and here's what
i'll say i'll give you a pithy answer
we'll expand on it
my pithy answer is this a minimal a
minimalist life is a well
curated life let me do that again my
pithy answer
is a minimalist life is a well
curated life that's also ultimately what
we're talking about here today when
we're talking about any of this type of
clutter
obviously on the private podcast this
week ryan will get more into the sort of
mental clutter the additional physical
clutter
hidden clutter etc but what we're
talking about is curating
our life think of a museum the reason
it's beautiful isn't because it has
nothing in it
it has the things that are essential the
building itself and then the things that
add
value the art which changes regularly
and so
but it doesn't have any of the excess
stuff
that is what we're talking about when
we're talking about
clutter now sebastian's question
specifically has to do with
digital clutter we've talked a bit about
that with lauren's question but this is
a different question this is hey we've
replaced
cds dvds books with
my kindle or netflix or apple music or
whatever
we've swapped one problem for another
i don't know that i agree with that
necessarily that's it's swapping a
boulder for a
pebble yeah pebbles can certainly be
annoying especially they get caught in
your shoe
right but the physical stuff is a
boulder
the digital stuff especially if we
curate that
as well which i think it's a fair point
like we don't want to sign up for a
bunch of different subscriptions yeah
that we never use
that's just a waste of money and if you
want to waste money that's fine
but i i don't see the reasoning behind
that in fact on
the private podcast this week ron i want
to talk to you about i'm going to give
you a list of all the things i just
unsubscribed to this past weekend
and because uh you're going to be asking
me some questions about the news and
stuff so
anyway there was one last word that
stood out to me in sebastian's question
now last sentence he said how do we
appropriately curate these
multiple digital subscriptions and still
satisfy ourselves since each service has
programs exclusive to its platform
well-written question and what i'll say
is
most of the things that we think are
satisfying
are not nourishing right yeah
and so am i being nourished by this is
it actually increasing my well-being or
is it
only bringing me pleasure yeah no
i i totally agree um a piece of me wants
to say
if you're looking towards these things
for satisfaction uh you will never be
satisfied so i mean
just reiterating how yeah nourishment
and satisfaction are not the same
um my pithy answer is this sebastian
stop searching for answers and start
taking action
and uh i mean you could even make that
pithier and just say that truth leads to
action but here's the thing is
sebastian is searching for an answer how
how do i do this
what's the appropriate amount there's
obviously
some discontent that's happening right
now
and uh sebastian you don't need
a how-to in order to start taking action
so i think that applies to a lot of
things where sometimes we
we search for answers and we use that as
an excuse to not
take action and if you understand the
why deep enough
then the how to tends to take care of
itself and the reason that happens is
you're gonna know like oh crap i look at
my bank statement
and i have 13 different subscriptions to
the new york times and to hulu
and to showtime and and all of these
different
platforms some of them might be adding
value to your life
you're going to know that if you
can be candid with yourself you're going
to have that gut feeling
and so that's why there isn't as ryan
says a how-to of well yes here are the
seven services you
everyone should have and then that's it
you're a minimalist
because that could be extreme overkill
for someone yeah and for someone else
that might not be
enough and so identifying what is
enough will help you identify what is
clutter
oh tweet that podcast sean boom ron
we've got some listener comments in our
added value segment in a moment
but we also have some surprise questions
this week like what are the biggest
examples of hidden clutter in your
household
we're going to hear some examples from
our listeners
we've got a bunch of different examples
we'll get to as many of those as we can
plus
we're going to do something a little bit
different this week ryan is going to
interview
me about how and why
i stopped watching the news cold turkey
and what it has done to my life
well it's interesting because i stopped
looking at the news back in october
right and then i picked it back up and
now i can't set it down like well i
shouldn't say i can't it's
it's more difficult for me to set it
down now than what it was
in october right when i set it down and
so it's going to be a broader
conversation than just the news it'll
start with the news media but
i think it'll go into really this he has
11 questions for me
what i would call intentional
consumption
now a lot of it has to do with the news
media or the
where we put our attention the
intention behind our attention right
and and so figuring out the intentions
behind
what we're doing so we can remove some
of these attachments
and so ryan for the first time ever is
going to interview
me and if you want to hear that you can
listen to this week's
private podcast visit theminimalists.com
support to subscribe to the minimalist
private podcast you'll get a personal
link
so that podcast plays in your favorite
podcast
app it's cheaper than a cup of coffee
and it keeps our show
100 advertisement free private podcast
subscribers
also gain access to hundreds of hours
of our private archives and they also
gain access to our love
it's two bucks it's only two dollars for
our love no we love all of you no matter
what
ryan what else you got for us this week
i have some voicemail
comments and insights from our listeners
check them out
hi my name is kelly i've actually been
binge listening to some of your episodes
on my long commute to work
and had a couple of low-cost solutions
based on your episodes on school and
food
so for people who are considering going
to college or
graduate school and aren't sure if it's
right for them
there is actually an online company
called coursera
they offer courses and
for some of them you can actually earn a
certification
they offer online courses that are
offered
by universities and taught by
university professors and all different
kinds of topics
right now i'm actually taking the
content management course
through northwestern university and the
subscription to do this is
fifty dollars a month so you can take
the courses
at your own pace finish at your own pace
and at the end
if you decide to finish you get a
certificate if you don't decide to
finish
you can unsubscribe so it's a low-cost
way to
kind of dabble in higher education if
you're trying to figure out
if school is something that you're
interested in and since they offer
classes on all kinds of topics you can
also dabble
in different areas or majors to see
where your interest may lie
in regards to the food episode i know
there some people expressed concerns
about wanting to eat organic
but the cost was a deterrent for them
there is actually a new company called
imperfect
produce and what they do is they
offer organic and or
non-organic options for delivery
actually
they take the produce that otherwise
would have been
sent to a landfill or not bought by
grocery stores just because
the produce might be a little large it
might be a little small
it might not look what we call perfect
and those are often the groceries that
are overlooked at the grocery store
so what they do is they take that
produce and they actually
sell it you can customize your box
online
and decide what you want whether it's
every week or every other week
and the box actually shows up at your
door it's
uh a company that's growing
so they don't offer for all cities but
they're slowly expanding
it's very inexpensive and you get
organic produce
delivered straight to you for a cost
that would be much lower than buying it
at say whole foods or
a grocery store that has expensive items
hi guys uh my name is maria i'm from
moscow russia uh i have a bipolar
disorder and most of the time i don't
have a lot of energy so stuff
uh kind of piles up um whenever i do
have it i start decluttering
and i don't just get rid of things i
don't need
or like or haven't used in a while i
also
ask myself does this thing makes me feel
better about myself
or worse for example i'm good at cooking
and since
i have to eat i cook once a week or so
but mostly i live on takeouts and
orderings um and even though i always
order healthy food and have a pretty
good eating habits
i still feel guilty about not having
home cooked meals
i never wanted to cook in the first
place but having all those cooking stuff
and not using it put stress on me it's a
three times a day struggle so
last month i said to myself okay i don't
want to worry about that anymore
it makes me like myself less
so i got rid of most of my kitchenware
and kept only few things essential to
making
eggs and coffee i
instantly felt better without all those
pans and pots
staring at me every time i enter my
kitchen
i don't have that stress anymore and
while i don't recommend that particular
kind of cleanup
i will definitely say to anyone with
bipolar or depression
that having only things that you like to
use or just
look at will make you feel so much
better
i know that most of us think one day
i'll get better and i finish that book
or diy project but sometimes not doing
that
is what makes you closer to getting
better so
throw it out find it in your home
you don't want stuff dragging you down
all right joel for our added value this
week we're going to play out at the end
of this episode with
toby and the wig wheeze song eat it's
the opening
track from his new album cinco
reginals and ryan i sent you this album
and i've been i've been wearing it out
man my tapes almost busted
remember when you used to be able to
wear out a cassette tape
oh man i still can watch me
all right real quick for right here
right now here's one thing that's going
on in the life of
the minimalists it's uh end of january
as we're recording this and publishing
this means you have a few days left to
pre-order our book love people use
things and get that pre-order bundle it
comes with some wallpapers for your
smartphone and your computer
also a sticker for your your computer
you can hide that
logo on your computer with a love people
use things
sticker and a bumper sticker as well a
lot of people use things bookmark you
can take that message with you wherever
you go
also the audiobook is now available for
pre-order and yes we know that
half of you are overseas thank you for
listening
love people use things is coming to a
country near you
stay tuned for details if you're on our
email newsletter you'll be the first
to hear about any foreign releases but i
know we have it coming out in
at least a dozen languages at this point
probably more
than that love people use things.net if
you want to pre-order the book
by the way if you don't want all the
pre-order bundle stuff that's fine too
you just don't have to submit for it and
then you won't get it right
some people are like i don't want a
bookmark i don't want a bumper sticker
like
i know milburn doesn't have a bumper
sticker on his car i don't
i don't but i put bumper stickers all
over ryan's car when he's not paying
attention
that's a lot of people use things.net
you can see the
beautiful new trailer that jordan filmed
for the book
as well love people use things dot net
bumper sticker we put on your mom's car
yes we can talk about that only on the
private podcast fair enough
[Laughter]
let's just say her priest found it yes
remind me we'll talk about that this
week all right follow the minimalist on
facebook twitter
and instagram at the minimalist come to
one of our live podcast shows visit the
minimalists.com tour to find a city near
you
if you have a question comment or
minimalism tip for our podcast email
a voice memo to podcast at
theminimalists.com
you can comment on this episode
youtube.com slash the minimalist and if
you want our show notes in your inbox
sign up for our email list over at
theminimalists.com we'll never send you
spam or junk or advertisements
but we will send you our simple sunday
emails each week in addition to those
podcast notes and if you leave here
today with just one message
we hope it's this love people and use
things
because the opposite never works thanks
for listening yo we'll see you next time
[Music]
every little thing you think that you
need
every little thing you think that you
need
every little thing that's just feeding
your greed oh i bet that you'll be fine
without it
bye